okay I'll repeat exactly what I said  again as a woman I am very nurturing and  I'll be a great a great mother I know  that I don't know listen I don't need  anyone to to tell me this or not because  none of you actually know me in my  private life in my personal life which  means never yes wait wait no you don't  actually you don't you actually don't  you know you actually don't you really  don't know what I do on a daily basis  and that's why I say for me what I am  thinking of the child because I would  rather have a very healthy relationship  with somebody that have a child with  that is not based on possession or  having to try and get on I don't want to  have to do that because the friction is  going to go on the kids so instead my  main focus will be on keeping myself  happy so I can give the best that I am  to my child  but does that child need two parents  yeah and they'll have two parents I'm  not going to take the child away